[Music]
relax
anything India be dead by now
there she is
the indominus rex
specimen collected sent to the surface
Roger that air one clear for takeoff
begin tracking up go go drinking
land one the asset is secure we got what
we came for coming back to you close the
doors
marine one I got to close the gate get
out of it understood
red now
breehn one I need to close the gates
confirm position and you hear me are you
out marine one guys
what is that seriously guys I'm kind of
exposed out here marine one
confirm you're out marine one confirm
position can you hear me marine one
where are you
I can't breathe stamps what
what is going on I can't hear
[Music]
we're gonna stop it now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
DNA sample secured Della Bosca coming
back home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
three years after the fall of Jurassic
world the debate over Isla Nublar rages
on the islands long dormant volcano
reclassified as active has shown
considerable unrest in recent months
geologists now predict an
extinction-level event will kill off the
last living dinosaurs on the planet
since the disaster that shocked the
world in 2015 the masrani corporation
has paid out more than 800 million in
damages to settle class-action lawsuits
brought by survivors activist groups
have mobilized around the globe in what
has become the flashpoint
animal rights issue of our time with an
eruption expected at any moment the US
Senate has convened a special committee
to answer a grave moral question do
dinosaurs deserve the same protections
given to other endangered species or
should they be left to die I think that
we should allow our magnificent glorious
dinosaurs to be taken out by the volcano
silence is deeply sad as that would be
we altered the course of natural history
this is a correction are you suggesting
the almighty is taking matters in his
own hands
senator with all due respect guts not
part of the equation no what I mean is
that in the last century we amassed a
landmark technological power and we've
consistently proven ourselves incapable
of handling that power 80 years ago who
could have predicted nuclear
proliferation but then there it was and
now we've got genetic power so how long
is it going to take for that to spread
around the globe and what's gonna be
done with it they ain't gonna stop with
the extinction of the dinosaurs I'm not
sure I know what you're talking about
I'm talking about two man-made
cataclysmic change
what kind of change changes like death
you don't know what it looks like until
you're standing at the gates
[Music]
that's a real thing no I haven't seen
one with my own eyes you know not
everyone can afford to spend their life
savings hello hello congresswoman
Delgado I'm Claire I'm the lead
organizer here of course but if I could
just get a moment of your time
great thank you
so our mission here at the dinosaur
protection group is to super of federal
funding I was like 40 seconds are
getting better you got to stop letting
your mom shop for you you don't need to
insult me every time someone pisses you
off dude
a doctor not a telemarketer what is your
job again you plug in cords right it's
actually a more importantly than it
sounds can I ask you a question do you
have kids okay so your kids an entire
generation has grown up in a world where
dinosaurs are living and breathing but
soon they're gonna have to watch them go
extinct or not if people like you make a
difference
[Music]
do you remember the first time you saw a
dinosaur gang blue we don't really
believe it it's like a miracle
[Music]
something's coming this is your exit
you're right it's not a t-rex
[Applause]
it'll come with me you know you can't
stay here
Jurassic world the island
your honor easy girl all of that is in
the past
my dad got kid
I want to show you the future what is
that thing they made it
[Music]
you need to get us out of here yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you